hello everyone and welcome to that other
special game that I've mentioned in the
previous video from round 10 of this
year's Tata steel Masters it is
Alexander donchenko versus gesh uh and
it's a really a wild game it's U not
even a game this is this is an execution
what you will see here and uh both of
them are having an interesting event but
GES has is having a great event he did
get those two losses um at Ding luren
and danish giri but then he defeated
three rounds in a row he defeated Max
vmer Anish giri not Anish giri Yan pishi
and Jordan P forest and donchenko was
struggling to get a single win in the
tournament but then in the previous
round he defeated none other than ala
fuja so uh let's check out what happened
here it's uh it's a very nice game
donchenko has the wi pieces and he opens
with D4 we have Knight to F6 C4 E6
Knight to C3 and Bishop to B4 so the nzo
Indian defense is on the board E3 and
now Castles by by gukesh we have Bishop
to D3 the so-called Bishop attack
against the Nimo and pawn to D5 just
striking against the center C captures e
captures and pawn to A3 so very standard
stuff here much like you would see in uh
any other nzo game Bishop to D6 and
queen to C2 uh we have Pawn to C6 uh
strengthening the center here and you
don't have to worry about this Knight
you nicely cover the B5 and D5 squares
Knight G to E2 and now Rook to E8 with
Bishop to D2 and now Knight B to D7 so
again all been play before nothing new
Here pawn to F3 still uh waiting with
castles but you are hinting at a
possible uh future E5 and now Pawn to C5
until white decides what to do you will
strike against White Center as the the
white king is still stuck on E1 so here
Pawn to H4 you could also Castle King
side here you could also Castle Queen
side here but um Alexander goes for to
H4 and it's not a new move it has been
played before uh um you know most
notable game that I could find is Wesley
saw versus Samuel seian Wesley so played
this last year or not last year in 2022
in the US championship against Samuel
seian but Wesley lost that game Sean
replied with Ponto H5 but here we have
Knight to B6 and it is now as of move 12
that we have a completely new game uh so
okay Pawn to G4 Alexander continues
marching forward uh and Knight to C4
you're probably expecting C captur on D
four you know it's we often say it's
principle when one side attacks on the
king side you have to strike in the
center especially if your opponent's
king is on E1 uh but gukesh of course
knows that and he's very strong and he's
allowed to break that rule he plays
Knight to C4 uh and now Bishop captures
on C4 you have to do something the E3
Pawn is attacked twice so Bishop
captures on C4 D captures on C4 and now
again not Castle Queen side or something
Pawn to D5 just uh keeping those Pawns
doubled uh and now uh Rook to B8
preparing to strike with Pawn to B5 and
again one would expect Pawn to A4 just
stopping that uh but no we just have a
continuation on the king Side Pawn to H5
we have Pawn to B5 and Here pawn to G5
so this is um this is more of a more of
a barart fight than a chess game as it
seems uh you know neither player is
really reacting to what the other guys
doing we have Knight to D7 and now Pawn
to F4 just continuing the happy march on
the king side we have Bishop to f8 will
help out with the defense of the king
side and now Pawn to H6 we have Pawn to
G6 and Rook to D1 uh just nicely
aligning that Rook with the black queen
and um you could try some other moves
you could try castles here castles is is
even one of the top engine moves here
even though your pawns are far Advanced
they're still sort of Defending you
against the black's forces so castling
King side definitely makes sense
castling Queen side not so much you run
into B4 right away but here Rook to D
one was played and now uh Knight to B6
by GES we have King to F2 and now Pawn
to B4 striking on the queen side uh
Knight to E4 or you could capture once
but doesn't really matter Knight to E4
and now Bishop to F5 pinning the Knight
here and here Knight to to G3 just
defending the Knight and preparing
Knight captures on F5 but the position
is now completely winning for GES but
you have to see at least five moves
ahead to figure out why uh feel free to
pause the video and win the game for G
cash while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
realizing that uh on Knight F6 check at
some point you will sacrifice your queen
temporarily and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures on e4 that's the move uh and
now after Knight captures on e4 Queen to
E7 is played or getting ready to to pick
up the Knight on e4 Knight to F6 check
and now Queen captures an F6 played
without much hesitation as the queen on
C2 is hanging and now there's a big
problem here if you if you play G
captures on F6 then just Bishop captures
on C2 and you're just uh up to too much
material there's um nothing to for white
to really do here so here donchenko
throws in Pawn to E4 now what can GES do
here well he plays Pawn to Queen to D4
with check King to F3 and now look at
this queen captures on D E5 absolutely
beautiful if you capture the queen then
Bishop captures Queen and of course you
cannot capture the bishop as the E Pawn
is pinned by the queen and if you
capture the queen then again you get
this position where white is in a
hopeless situation Pawn to B3 yeah okay
you do have two Rooks um you do have a
rook for a bishop and Knight but uh it's
completely unplayable uh so instead
after Queen captures on D5 Alexander
figures out how to maybe play this
bishop captures on B4 is played opening
up an attack towards the White Queen but
now Bishop captures on e4 with check
Queen captures Queen captures with check
King captures and C captures on B4 we
have a captures and Bishop captures on
B4 and we have this position where gkes
has a bishop and Knight for a rook and
he's also up a pawn now uh is there any
counterplay here for white well if you
can activate your Rooks yes there
certainly is but if you can't then no uh
here Rook to D4 was played and
interestingly gukesh goes for a mini
repetition here Bishop to C5 Rook back
to D2 Bishop to B4 uh Rook to D4 Bishop
to C5 and now Rook to D2 as gukesh was
down to some 13 minutes on the clock
donchenko had I believe 23 minutes on
the clock and gkes wanted to reach time
control as soon as possible but of
course now he doesn't repeat now he
plays Pawn to F5 with check freeze up
the F7 Square for his King and this is
how he advances further in the game G
captures on F6 King to F7 uh now Rook to
A1 going after the A7 Pawn but just Rook
to B 7 uh we have Rook to d8 trying to
go after the maybe the H7 Pawn maybe the
A8 Pawn if the knight ever moves but uh
you know at least you have an active
Rook King captures on F6 now comes Rook
to A6 spinning the Knight here uh so the
the Knight for the moment cannot be
moved uh Rook to E7 with check kicking
the white king further back King to F3
and now King back to F7 unpinning we
have Rook to h8 going after the pawn and
King back to E6 we have Rook to A8 now
again the Knight cannot move so the
threat is Rook captures Pawn here and
gash has to figure out how to play this
now uh the objectively best is King to
D5 but this is U does not look like a
very human way to play King D5 you're
going to allow Rook captur on A7 now
you're going to block with Knight to D7
open up a discovery here and after Rook
E8 Rook to E3 with check and this is how
you uh progress further King G4 Bishop
to D6 um and so on however here after
Rook to A8 uh gkes played a more human
uh move Bishop to D4 just goes after the
B2 Pawn once you eliminate it you just
Advance the C3 Pawn at to Victory so
here Rook eight captures on A7 we have
Rook captures Rook captures and now
Knight to C8 attacking the rook and
offering the H7 Pawn uh and while you
could capture it first Rook to C7 just
attacking the the Knight and the pawn on
uh on C4 Knight to D6 now defending and
only now Rook captures an H7 H but it's
not much better as there is a win here
for GES however there is only one move
that wins here for gach and it shows
just how precise you have to be in an
end game even if you have a bishop and
Knight for a rook feel free to pause the
video and show us your endgame skill uh
or or rather endgame prowess while I
give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who able to
do it congratulations on being a true
Master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Knight to F7 the only move that wins
for gukesh and I will show you why okay
you you can play Bishop capture some B2
you hope to advance the pawn all of a
sudden Rook to C7 comes and now okay the
pawn is defended nothing to it and even
if you advance the pawn to C3 it will be
defended by the bishop but um uh H how
to progress here let's say go Knight F7
uh go after the pawn pawn to eight H7
how do you stop h8 queen or rather uh
how do you progress here with black the
the bishop for the moment covers the h8
square but if you play Pawn to C3 then
just Rook captures Knight and then you
advance the pawn to a queen so here
there's really no good way uh to
continue uh it would be a draw that's
why after Rook captures on H7 Knight to
F7 is the only precise move that wins
the game we have Rook to G7 again hoping
to get some counter playay here but I'm
sure both of them know that it's over
Bishop captures Pawn captures and now
like in the previous game you cannot
reach the pawn um by by the Knight alone
you also have to use your opponent's
king So Knight to H6 okay you're
guarding the the queening square now uh
King to E4 and now King to D6 we have
King to D4 now comes Knight to F5 with
check and you've eliminated the Pawn
King captures and C4 Knight captures and
G7 H we have King to D4 and Knight to F5
with check King to E4 now comes King K
to E6 and of course white does have the
past B Pawn but um uh there's not much
you can do with it Knight to E7 uh we
have King to F3 and King to F5 Pawn to
B5 now comes Knight to D5 and here King
to G3 and here gukesh has to calculate
is it okay to capture the F4 Pawn he
calculates precisely he plays Knight
captures on F4 and he was in this
position on move 57 that Alexander
donchenko resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so he did
take down one candidate in the previous
round but it will not be two candidates
today and the reason you resign here is
that again the Knight will use a check
to reach the pawn uh for example uh
after Knight captures on F4 what do you
play you play Pawn to B6 here uh you you
don't go after the pawn right away if
you go after the pawn right away then
the pawn marches forward and becomes a
queen but after B6 you just give one
check and now your knight is perfectly
positioned King F2 Knight to D4 Pawn to
B7 and now Knight to C6 guards the
queening square uh and that's that's all
there is now you'll just start advancing
your pawn and King uh promote your your
G pawn and win the game easily uh so
yeah very nicely done by gesh spotting
that uh spotting that nasty tactic or
rather both of those nasty tactic uh
this one okay this one uh was very nice
but I also enjoyed the the one in the
end game so if you found both of them uh
really big congratulations to you uh so
as uh I've shown in the previous video
maybe some of you haven't seen it if you
haven't do check it out it's a wonderful
game but these are the standings after
10 Rounds have been played in the Tata
still 2024 so Norbeck and gesh sharing
first place with six and a half three
more rounds to go so anything can happen
Anish gari and PR on six points on five
and a half points we have four people V
ala Yani pishi with four points param
maulu Jun ding L and Max vam and with
three and a half points Alexander
donchenko and Jordan forest and um uh
here are the the results of the of the
other rounds if uh you haven't seen them
so juvenon Drew against Parham Max lost
to nck Ala Drew against Anish vit Drew
against pranda donchenko lost against
gash this is the game that we've now
shown yordan Drew against Wei and Yani
pishi defeated ding Len in that
beautiful beautiful game again if you
haven't seen it do check it out and um
yeah I don't have it here but I will
tell you uh the the next three opponents
for our leaders so in the final three
games GES will face fuja prand and
makulu so not not an easy pairing for
GES in the final three rounds uh and um
uh for uh for our good friend n
abdat the last three rounds for him will
be Jen Jun viit and Alexander donchenko
but okay I mean everyone is playing
strong chess here you have to be a
strong player but uh yeah I I would say
that if I had to to say who has the
tougher pair up I would say GES has the
the tougher pairings uh going into the
final three rounds so we'll see what
happens here Norbeck in excellent
position to win the tournament but gkes
is a candidate and he he he he's here to
prove it so hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Christopher and Ruth
brette Anna olier mhmed sones Usman AAS
Minas Anda Teresa for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day